hey guys it is Friday once again which
means I'm here to get you all caught up
on the biggest things that happened in
gaming this week stella's of eternity
developers obsidian entertainment and
paradox interactive have announced their
next project the PC RPG called tyranny
will take place in quote an original
fantasy world where Aboriginal clash
between good and evil is taking place
and evil emerged triumphant the game's
story will be nonlinear and call for
players to make difficult morally grey
decisions tyranny will release later
this year and put you in the shoes of an
officer in an evil Legion it looks like
you'll be able to decide whether to be a
good guy or a bad guy through your
interactions with the inhabitants night
does studios have released of the first
gameplay video from System Shock
remastered the remake is developed in
beauty and looks really bloody pretty
particularly if you can cast your mind
back to how the original game looked the
new clip shows off the new user
interface and lovely visuals night I've
explained they will keep the new game
true to the classic experience
presumably in that you will still get
the ships get out of you rounding
corners and you can still hit monsters
with a pipe system shop remastered is
due out on Xbox one and PC next year and
night dive also working on the upcoming
System Shock 3 in Hardware news AMD have
announced absolutely the most powerful
graphics card in the world by far their
words not mine earlier this week at GDC
Andy revealed the radio and pro duo
which they're calling the world's first
content creation platform aimed squarely
at the VR developer the dual GPU
features to fury x-class graphics cards
running side-by-side the two graphics
chips on one card are designed to reduce
latency while the card also makes use of
AMD's liquid via framework and boasts 16
teraflops of computing performance the
card will arrive later this year and has
a 90 $1,500 price tags this week
PlayStation finally threw their hat in
the ring and announced the price and
roll
window for their vr offering which is
sadly no longer called Morpheus the
slightly less cool sounding PlayStation
VR is going to cost four hundred dollars
in North America and will arrive in
October of this year although you should
add on the price of a PlayStation camera
on top of that this one is weirdly not
included in the package the SVR also
doesn't come with move controllers which
are required for some games so that'll
hike up the price a bit more
nevertheless even with the additions
it's still cheaper than the six hundred
dollar oculus rift and the eight hundred
dollar HTC vive sony also confirmed over
230 developers are making games for PSP
are right now and more than 160 games
are currently in development sony also
revealed that all ps4 games will be
playable within the virtual cinema mode
which displays the game up on a virtual
5 meter screen in front of you finally
Sony and Microsoft seem to be talking
pretty seriously about connecting the
Xbox Live and PlayStation networks on
Monday microsoft announced that it will
natively support cross-platform play
between xbox one Windows 10 and other
online multiplayer networks which makes
it sound like all sony has to do is
opt-in so you responded that they have
supported cross-platform play between
PlayStation consoles and PC for several
titles and they would be quote happy to
have the conversation with any
publishers or developer so interested in
cross-platform play both Microsoft and
Sony have strangely avoided mentioning
each other specifically but the
hypothetical future looks to be
progressing positively so far then we're
down in that comment section if you'd
like to see PlayStation and Xbox adduct
cross-platform play between networks
this week on site I tell you about some
sweet division easter eggs on the gist
al-falih full show checks out strums
power armor and we interview Theon
Greyjoy from Game of Thrones that is
everything I happy this week but be sure
to have yourselves a lovely weekend and
Mary will be back with your gaming news
on Monday